bonsoir monsieur couture
bonsoir monsieur fillion recyclage
league sion vient de conclure une
importante ronde de financement pour la
construction de sa première usine de
recyclage de batteries lithium lithium
ion au québec expliquez-nous ce que ça
veut dire pour vous ça
ben et pour nous c'est très important on
a fondé l'entreprise en 2018 et puis
depuis ce temps là on ne construit une
première usine pilote de démonstration
pour démontrer notre procédé puis le
tester sur des vraies batterie qui
viennent du marché des batteries de
cellulaires de laptops demetri de taux
des batteries d'autobus alors on a testé
la technologie avec ça ils notre
objectif c'était d'être capable d'aller
à tirer des services à vous venez nous
donner la capacité de finalement
déployée commercialement de technologie
et là vous avez réussi à cirer ses
investitures y sera fait et puis je
prends contact e en plus on est des
investisseurs étrangers ont là on a
envie de l'investissement étranger ici
au québec pour construire ici un centre
technique qui va continuer le
développement de technologies puis une
première usine qui va servir les besoins
de recyclage des québécois reste à
savoir à quel endroit dans la région de
montréal
ça va dans la région montréal c'est
certain parce qu'on exploite nous c'est
la mienne aubaine alors on n'a pas
encore choisi le site actuellement les
dans l'est de montréal depuis il est
situé à ville d'anjou c'est une zone qui
nous intéresse beaucoup on est bien
situé donc l'est de montréal est très
intéressante notre usine et les ulcères
à exploiter la mine urbaine comme si
c'est pour aller chercher les batteries
en fin de vie puis créer des nouveaux
matériaux de 28 ans aucune économie
circulaire pour ramener et matériaux un
matériau de 4,28 l'ensemble des
matériaux stratégiques comparative à ce
qui se fait actuellement actuellement
c'est la pyrométallurgie qui
principalement utilisés the bull a dû
fin pratique les batteries ou le
matériel de batterie ils vont chercher
moins de 50% nous on va chercher 95% des
éléments stratégiques de la vie puis on
fabrique des matériaux grammes batterie
qui vont réintégrer la chaîne
d'approvisionnement alors simple sincère
extrêmement bien dans la stratégie
depuis la fia doit être l'heureux
millions dont parlait il ya quelques
minutes et c'est quoi vos ambitions
mais notre technologie on l'a déploie
mondialement par un modèle de licence de
procéder alors ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
a choisi de ne pas devenir les
opérateurs des usines partout dans le
monde on pense que c'est beaucoup plus
efficace beaucoup plus rapide de
licencier notre technologie à des
opérateurs existants alors partout dans
le monde des entreprises qui recycle les
véhicules actuellement qui re sic des
batteries actuellement ils ont juste
besoin d'avoir accès à une technologie
durable fiable comme celle que non qu'on
a conçu pour pouvoir servez-le à
remâcher le calme et vous avez déjà une
licence à l'asile en corée du sud cette
semaine
exactement alors ça c'est la deuxième
excellente nouvelle cette semaine on a
un client avec une licence pour
développer le marché asiatique alors on
est extrêmement bien le marché de
l'accord est il déjà en avance sur nous
on est juste à penser un round et à
samson
sgl jsk c'est des leaders dans le marché
de l'électrification des transports
aussi de la batterie lithium-ion le
marché très mature la banque puis à
hiesse donc c'est au recycle déjà des
batteries lithium-ion mais avec une
vieille technologie une technologie
basée sur l'i aux températures
sont une voire deux technologies puis
quand ils ont vu les résultats qu'on
obtenait du sein des démonstrations ont
été très impressionnés qu'ils vont
transformer toute leur succès dans notre
technologie ont même construit une
nouvelle usine utilisent notre
technologie alors on va commencer on
commence déjà travaillé avec les équipes
là bas vous livre le petit musée le
ministre fait qui est bonne a dit cette
semaine votre projet très intéressant
est-ce que vous recevez vous recevrez
prévoyez recevoir des investissements
des subventions de la part du
gouvernement
depuis les tout débuts du projet
le
ministère de l'économie le ministère de
l'environnement supporte très bien le
projet
je peux vous dire qu'on est déjà en
discussion avec le gouvernement du
québec par la filiale des batteries
li-ion l'alignement stratégique québec
prend pour développer cette filière là
et puis aussi par des appuis financiers
on compte avoir continué à recevoir
beaucoup de support de notre
gouvernement et c'est très important
pour chris nouvelle industrie là qui est
vraiment importante c'est un projet
porteur pour l'ensemble des québécois
puis je suis fier de participer à cette
aventure est créateur d'emploi vous avez
combien d'employés
actuellement de 17 employés et à partir
de lundi on va en avoir dix neuf on
continue comme ça ma bouche et d'autre
on prévoit avoir 100 employés avec notre
usine est notre centre technique vous
disais qu'on fait un centre technique ce
très important on doit de rencontre la
technologie des batteries lithium-ion
évoluent extrêmement rapidement beaucoup
d'investissements la part des
équipementiers de la part des fabricants
de batteries nous on doit dire que notre
technologie votre capable de suivre sa
confiance en technique alors vous aussi
assuré l'appui de nous dit sensible
alors félicitations bravo et bonne
chance pour la suite merci monsieur
culture d'avoir été avec nous ce soir le
faisait merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]